good day everyone and thank you for
being present to listen to our poster
presentation which is entitled
elucidating the potential impact of
circulating plasmodium falciparum
dihydroterrorist
synthesis
variants on sulfur dioxin perimeter
resistance in ghana and across africa
this project was conducted in
collaboration with nigel
james and benedict are under the
supervision of eli and mohit from the
pine biotech team and our pi dr anita
ganza from gucci my memorial institute
for medical research in ghana
malaya continually threatens global
public health interventions especially
in sub-saharan africa over the years
high mobility and mortality rate are
caused by the malaria causative species
plasmodium falciparum
despite the global eradication and
control efforts
resistance to various forms of
anti-malaria therapeutics have been a
major standing block in ghana
sulfadoxane pyramid pyramidamine is used
as an effective agent for intermittent
preventive treatment for pregnant women
and children
sp function by inhibiting plasmodium
hydro
dihydrothyroid synthesis and
dihydrophilic synthesis interfering with
foliates and synthesis a previous data
of plasmodium falciparum ghps isolates
from danian parasite highlighted a high
prevalence of the mutations at position
581
being mutated to
glycoglycine and at position 613b
mutated to serene in the forest and
coastal regions of ghana interestingly
these two mutations have been associated
with resistance to sulfadoxin
and exist as a rare occurrence globally
therefore in this study we sought to map
out sulfadoxin resistance and assess how
the two mutations are spreading across
ghana and other african countries we
therefore hypothesize that
the two mutations at position 581
mutated into glycine and at position 61
imitated into serene are spreading
across ghana and other sub-saharan
african countries and could be one of
the driving forces of resistance in
africa
for our metal to this project the sample
size of the study was 8 000
8044 parasites isolate which were
extracted from 28 countries the samples
were created from the plasmodium
community project for the malaria gene
repository and data collected in ghana
from two ecological zones between the
year 2014 and 2017.
our objectives were divided into two
firstly to identify the diversity of
mutation alanine 581 by to glycine and
11613 to serene in ghana and across
africa
to achieve the objectives data
processing variant colon and haplotype
analysis were done
secondly the potential effect of
identified haplotypes were evaluated on
the structure of plasmodium falciparum
dhps to achieve these objectives
homology modelling of wild-type and
mutant structures were successfully done
mutant mapping and mutation analysis
were also performed we also performed
molecular docking and interaction
profiles
from the results as reported in the
forest and coastal regions in ghana
to the two mutation alanine 581 glycine
and 11613
[Music]
were also present in the savannah
regions where transition is high in
seasonal this suggests that the mutation
is coming up regardless of transmission
intensity and seasonality
furthermore investigation across the
other regions of africa and the world
show the presence of alanine fights it's
one glycine and alanine 6-1 tb serene in
west central east africa and also
southeast asia and south america
unsurprisingly the key mutation for
resistance which is alanine 437 glycine
were found to be present and almost at
fixation in all the regions another
critical mutation lysine 540 to
glutamine also had presence of five
percent and above in south east asia but
less than one percent in the other
regions which agree with literature
with regards to the haplotype analysis
17 unique haplotypes were found across
all regions with eight having noticeable
frequencies the double mutants haplotype
bearing alanine 581 glycine and alanine
six one theory serine were only present
in cameroon which is the country in
central africa most importantly alanine
581 glycine and then six months with
serene were found to be hits hiking and
with the key alarm 437 glycine and the
mutation is only present in west and
central africa at the moment
this does suggest that alanine 581
glycemic 613 mutations
are not being selected alone but rather
with alanine
437 glycine and the triple um haplotype
mutation is sweeping across from the
west
of africa towards the east and would
eventually reach southeast asia hence
it's present in west and
central africa only
the complete 3d structure of wild type
and mutant aladdin 581 glycine alanine
613 serum and other heart proteins were
successfully built through homology
modelling
when mapping onto 3d crystal structures
of the protein
gene it was observed that alanine
glycine occupies a crucial loop
structure of in the active site in close
proximity to an already known maca
resistant marker alanine 4 37 glycine
and lysine 540 and glutamine as seen in
figure 3
also alanine 6137 occurs on alpha
helical structure at the entrance of the
active site of the protein
as referred to and figuratively these
podia positions may have a vital effect
on sulfate dogs and
binding
amino acid changes resulted
in the change in physiochemical
properties of the protein which could
affect active site drug recognition
additionally mutations were predicted to
destabilize the active site by
molecular interactions
crucial for catalysis this
destabilization could result in
conformational changes which may affect
the binding of com of the compounds of
adoption
again we docked silvadoxin in the active
site of the wild type and mutant systems
which referring to figure 5. the
presence of mutation caused the loss of
molecular interactions surrounding the
protein position hydrogen bonds were
misplaced indicating
major structural and functional
recognition changes
with regards to table 3 we also noticed
that single mutants were predicted to
not
significantly decrease binding affinity
whereas double entropy mutation
significantly decreased binding affinity
source of adoption
from
figure 6 the wild type and in the super
doxing in wild type made several
hydrogen bonds hydrophobic interactions
and other molecular important molecular
interactions with active sites residues
crucial for drug recognition and
catalysis however in the presence of
mutations
resulted in change in interactions with
the drug and also formed unfavorable
interactions with tyrosine 61663
which could
result in steric clashes with the drug
in conclusion alanine 581 glycine
analysis one theory serine mutations are
gradually spreading across ghana and
other sub-saharan african countries by
occurring on same haplotype with known
plasmodium falciparum dhps gene markers
and hence increased surveillance is duly
recommended again structural analysis
suggests potential effects of mutation
on drug binding and structural functions
as future work running dynamic
simulation could additionally highlight
some resistance mechanisms which could
be a major foundation to discovery of
better drugs for
malaria treatment thank you for
listening